Hi!
My name is Brad and I am one of the Tech Leads
for Native Client.
In this video, I am going to dive into the
technology that makes Native Client apps possible.
A key concept in Native Client is the sandbox,
an isolation technique that prevents downloaded
code from doing things it’s not supposed
to.
The Native Client sandbox prevents application
code from interacting directly with the native
operating system.
This is crucial for portability.
If an app invoked the native OS directly,
it couldn’t run on other operating systems.
It’s also essential for security, because
the native operating system provides access
to resources like your files that need to
be protected.
The Native Client sandbox is implemented using
a technique called Software Fault Isolation.
This technique was first introduced in the
early 90’s.
It’s based on the use of assembly-language
idioms that are easy to recognize and that,
when used, make it possible to prove certain
things about the program’s behavior.
For example, if you insure that all data addresses
used by a program are greater than a particular
address, then you know that no memory references
can happen below that address.
Using software fault isolation we implement
what we call reliable disassembly.
This means that we know every instruction
a program can execute, and won’t run it
unless we can prove that each instruction
is safe.
Defense in depth is another key concept for
Native Client.
Suppose you had a brick of gold.
You might put it in a safe, but you wouldn’t
leave that safe sitting out in your front
yard.
Maybe you’d put it inside your house, maybe
even in a locked room, and you would probably
lock your house too.
In the same way, Native Client uses multiple
layers of protection that make it much harder
to attack the system.
We also apply best practices such as strict
coding standards and multiple internal and
external security reviews to insure that our
system is really safe.
Openness is another key principle we’ve
applied in this system.
We’ve built the system around established
open standards like HTML5, C, C++, POSIX and
ELF, to make it easily accessible to a large
community of developers.
We’ve open-sourced our system, because we’ve
seen that scrutiny and input from the developer
community makes our system better.
I hope you’ve enjoyed this quick overview
of some of the principles behind Native Client
technology.
To learn more visit our site at gonacl.com.